trudy está aprendiendo a manejar un
nuevo tipo de vehículo la velocidad del
vehículo está determinada por la
posición de una perilla giratoria la
velocidad del vehículo en millas por
hora la velocidad del vehículo en millas
por hora como función de la posición de
la perilla así que la velocidad del
vehículo es función de la posición de la
perilla bp se muestra en la siguiente
tabla p mayor que 0 de mayor que 0
significa que la perilla está girando en
el sentido del reloj y p menor que cero
menor que cero significa que la perilla
está girada en contra del reloj esta
función es impar cuál es el significado
de la paridad y bien entonces lo que
tenemos que es función de la posición de
la perilla es precisamente la velocidad
del vehículo así que esta vez es la
velocidad
ciudad
y p es precisamente la posición de la
perilla posición
la posición de la perilla no nos
preocupemos por ahora entonces aquí está
la tabla y me dicen que esta función es
impar
antes que nada recordemos que significa
que una función se impar y una función
es impar
sí solo si para todo valor de la sda es
igual a menos
efe de menos a o lo que es lo mismo
efe de menos a es igual a menos
efe de a estas dos cosas son
equivalentes y veamos que en este caso
si se cumple por ejemplo cuando la
posición de la perilla es menos 8 es
decir la perilla está girada en la
posición 8 en contra de las manecillas
del reloj
entonces la velocidad del coche es de 4
kilómetros por hora 4 millas por hora
perdón y cuando la posición es 8 a favor
de las manecillas del reloj entonces el
coche va a una velocidad de menos 44 es
menos -4 o menos 4 es lo mismo que menos
4 así que estas dos cosas son
inversas auditivas mutuamente también
cuando la posición de la perilla está en
-6 o sea la perilla está seis posiciones
en contra de las manecillas del reloj la
velocidad del coche es 3 y cuando está
en 6 o sea 6 posiciones a favor de las
manecillas del reloj el coche va a menos
3 millas por hora de nuevo son inversos
parece que cuando la posición de la
perilla está girada en contra de las
manecillas del reloj que serían estos
valores de aquí entonces el coche se
mueve hacia adelante con una velocidad
positiva el coche está avanzando y
cuando la posición de la perilla es en
cualquier punto del mismo modo que él se
mueve del mismo modo que las manecillas
del reloj el coche va en reversa porque
la velocidad es negativa así que esa es
la interpretación de que la función sea
impar mover la perilla a favor de las
manecillas del reloj produce que el
coche vaya en reversa y mover la perilla
en contra de las manecillas del reloj
hace que el coche avance por lo tanto
tienen efectos contrarios y cuáles son
nuestras opciones pues la primera opción
nos dice que la posición de las
adyacentes de la perilla resulta en
velocidades que son diferentes en medio
kilómetro por hora medio kilómetro por
hora pues quizás pero no sabemos
realmente cuál sea la posición en los
números impares así que realmente no
puedo afirmar esto la velocidad máxima
del vehículo es de 4 kilómetros por hora
de nuevo aquí la tabla termina en menos
8 y nos da un valor máximo de 4 por lo
que quizás sea cierto pero nada esto
tiene que ver con la imm paridad de la
función rotar en sentido de las
manecillas del reloj y en contra de las
manecillas del reloj tienen efectos
opuestos esto es precisamente lo que
está diciendo así que yo creo que esta
es la respuesta correcta veamos la
última opción rotar la perilla en
sentido del reloj hace que el vehículo
vaya hacia atrás eso también es cierto
porque la velocidad es negativa pero no
habla de la imm paridad por lo tanto
esta es la respuesta correcta